Tom Cech today well Emily now is the
former chairperson of Hong Kong's
Democratic Party joins us now Emily
welcome to you this new bill will
criminalize subversion the semantics of
that a potentially problematic aren't
they subversion could be a very broadly
defined word exactly and of course we
don't know what the content is going to
be as your reporter just said they're
going to us trash it out in the coming
weeks but it is it could be very broad
and it is not just the political
activists who are concerned I'm sure the
businesspeople the professionals who
travel to mania and China all the time
the same people who are very afraid of
the extradition bill which sparked off
months of protests and violence last
year and now they are incorporating all
of that extradition subversion secession
terrorism foreign interference and it
really could be the end of one country
two systems' yeah I dare say that maybe
that fear may be behind this is you in a
statement from the US UK Canada
Australia they say they are deeply
concerned by these by this new
legislation but that could be seen or
spun by j-bay Beijing as further further
examples of outside interference by the
old colonial powers well the thing is
Hong Kong is an international City I
don't know how many Britons live in Hong
Kong maybe a hundred thousand or more
than 80,000 Americans are here and
300,000 Canadians and hundreds of
thousands of Australians and so on so
it's a very international City so it's
not just hong kong people like myself
who are impacted it's all these foreign
citizens and their companies there are
thousands of foreign companies operating
here investing making money so if these
governments are concerned we can
understand and we certainly hope that
the international community will speak
out of course Britain has a risk
ability because it's the former colonial
power and I'm happy to see the joint
statement by the foreign ministers of
various countries on Friday the European
Union is going to meet
I hope Hong Kong will be on the agenda
and then of course the u.s. is kept
trying to get it on the agenda of the
United Nations and then make this month
the group of seven the most powerful
industrialized countries will meet in
America and I hope Hong Kong will be on
the agenda and today the Japanese
government came out to express deep
concern so I certainly hope that will
become a big issue in the international
community
in spite of the pandemic because of the
pandemic that's why China the Communist
Party thinks they can just rush it
through but I call on the international
community to speak out for the interests
of the seven million people but also for
your own citizens living and working in
Hong Kong and Emily do you think money
will talk if talk of civil liberties
doesn't and I looked at the statement
from the US Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo who said that Hong Kong could no
longer be considered to have quote a
high degree of autonomy from mainland
China and he's wondering out loud
whether perhaps investors will feel
quite so sure about investing there well
that's true and there is I've spoken to
some people and they think some of the
investors will leave and one place they
will go to is Singapore and they say
think a boy is already very very happy
because they would inherit many of these
people but and some of the business
people here tonight you see on TV
they're saying oh it doesn't matter and
we don't mind the tariffs well let's see
if it's really true and the stock market
in the coming days will tell us whether
it will continue to rise or it will
collapse you're right
Hong Kong is a business city and money
does talk and if the business people say
oh we're not afraid we're not afraid of
what the US government may do is it
really true let's find out but I want to
tell the US government not to punish
the seven million people but if they
want to target individuals in Hong Kong
and in mainland China
well beauty of growth whose human rights
violations by banning them by freezing
their properties and assets that's great
not just in America because there are
other countries even in the UK with the
Magnitsky Act and they can use it to
target these officials and politicians
Emily many people in this country will
remember those memorable scenes in 1997
the handover of Hong Kong and those
scenes of lorries of RB lorries from
China soldiers ramrod straight
stony-faced and are worried now that we
may see perhaps the installation of a
new type of security apparatus in Hong
Kong a much further extension of
Beijing's power into the way security
wise Hong Kong works exactly because
right now in Hong Kong they are three
only three mainland agencies which can
be set up here one is the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs and the People's
Liberation Army and the central
government liaison office but now
they're talking about setting up an
office for national security and maybe
they will say national security people
to come to Hong Kong to implement the
mainland law this is turning the
sino-british joint declaration and the
basic law on said it's a complete breach
of the joint declaration and breach of
the basic law and so that's why one
country to system is over it's one
country one system and that's why no
matter how busy he is I think Prime
Minister Boris Johnson must be eco and
you know you cannot betray the the
almost three million British citizens
who are living here British national
overseas citizens the B and O passport
holders they have no right of a boat in
the UK but they have British anyway so I
think many British people would agree
with me that the country has
responsibilities all of these people who
now face grave danger the baton of
opposition has passed from those in Hong
Kong who helped organize one country two
systems' back in the mid-1990s there is
a new generation of protesters and we
saw some in our correspondents report
just a few moments ago young people who
must it has now to be considered must
face risks going forward if they
continue to protest in the way they have
done well exactly and many people feel
very sorry for the younger generation
and of course many of them are not even
bno passport holders because they were
born after 1997 they feel very very
disappointed very upset very frustrated
and they don't really see a future
that's why they did they resorted to
such behavior I mean I don't support
violence I never did and but I can
understand why some people young or old
are so angry and and the way to deal
with the problem is not to send a police
out to beat them up to lock them up and
so on we've got almost 9,000 people
arrested already but not one single
police officer has been arrested for
police brutality the way to heal the
wounds is to started dialogue but now
the Communist Party is going in the
opposite direction they are going to use
more force or Hong Kong they even go to
send their national security people here
maybe to start arresting people or
sending them back to mainland China for
trial and over there of course it's
complete lawlessness Emily do you think
ordinary people in the West are watching
this and understanding what's happening
closely enough enough for instance in my
introduction to our report a few moments
ago I read that China's parliament I
mean I misspoke really we should we told
you to wear China's People's Congress
it's it's not a parliament in the way we
would understand it to be of course not
it's just a rubber-stamp
institution and but but that's the way
China is
and now of course there is this
wiccaning in the West thinking knowing
the true colors of the Communist Party
because for many years many leaders many
governments in the West that by engaging
the Communist Party engaging China they
will bring to China into the civilized
world become a responsible member of the
international community but now if I
know that's not happening whether it's
with democracy with locking people up
inseams young and other places now
trampling on the rights of Hong Kong and
the Wuhan virus all these things with
people up so I hope people will
understand and tell China that they
cannot behave in such a barbaric way and
Hong Kong tiny little Hong Kong but we
are a free vibrant and safe City and now
they want to destroy us Emily Lau is the
former chairperson of Hong Kong's
Democratic Party Emily though I really
appreciate your time today thank you
thank you